[Music]
the careful boys are [ __ ] rich let's
go
we made more money
is that from the super bowl
oh yeah how much how much money
let's talk about the winnings get out
get this out of here look we've seen
your losing ticket eight times already
what does this say what does it say
320
the size of the stack so small we
dropped it with
it didn't have the same matching
strippers i gotta make that in five
minutes what's wrong with your bet the
favorite heavily
happy face how many you should have
brought that one how much did you guys
win per person i i think we understand
because it was negative it was negative
309. it's negative money we lost money
no no no so we each one like 300 bucks
no no no so you put 200 we got like 130
or something like that you look like we
made 100. what's the net on what we made
four 130 pounds okay so gross three
thirty eight nine one thousand one
hundred two hundred three hundred four
hundred five hundred and twenty six
dollars five twenty six divided by five
yeah you guys did it's a 105 they could
give me a penny 105 and 20 cents guys
that's pretty good so we made 20 dollars
we made 105 dollars and 20 cents because
we're getting our 200 initially back
and then you got a tip
i would have won 320 bucks on the 200.
but what did you lose what did you
tell the [ __ ] guy at the book that
you would have it was a grandma she was
nice
yeah and then she gave me a drink
voucher i'm on a drink voucher okay she
gave me a drink voucher and she's here's
a huge [ __ ] list of bets you said it
was like 50 pages she gave me the whole
booklet right and you could bet on
everything everything coin toss
everything what what's the return on
bidding on the coin test correctly it's
[ __ ] crazy what was it
what was the return on your bet
you don't even want to know man 320.
you bet on the wrong one right so uh i
think this is gonna be a tradition from
now on where every super bowl i'm gonna
bet the underdog and you guys just bet
the favorite well sometimes we're going
to bet the underdog too how about we
brought batteries
around the city this time maybe joe's
underdog we bet on joe is there an
underdog for the coin toss
like that's not going dude heads or
tails it's not 50-50
i'll bring the booklet from vegas we'll
[ __ ] do the buckles should we do like
one dollar on every bet possible
i'm just gonna copy pelosi on the super
bowl basket oh that's a great idea
nancy who are you picking
okay if i don't first if i bet the
spread right i would have won if you bet
the spread you would have won yeah
because it was plus three yeah yeah i
think you would have won
yeah but you did explain that what's
plus three
i did outright because i wanted to win
big don't talk about all the better
jokes
like getting carried out
joe's entire life his book should be
like what i would have had so the
difference is three points because it
was pointing to three oh
i give my money
yeah sure how much is it uh it's 105 to
everybody you can keep my 20 cents as a
fee are there any bets on like a
cheerleader breaking her legs or
something
like from being being spun around i
think so everybody has 305 305
we should bet like who during the
halftime show is going to be a meme
because every halftime show there's
going to be a meme
bart only got 200. but the meme of the
halftime show is definitely 50 cent yeah
yeah yeah him hanging upside down the
cool meme was the eminem kneeling but
the hank upside down 50 was [ __ ]
funny get yourself a new pair of shoes
sweetie
yeah i don't know what to do with this
one five dollars short what's the rest
of it right here i was planning on um
you know i was planning on going to the
batman with you guys but nobody wants to
see batman except for me and anthony so
i want to oh [ __ ] this is going to
batman baby this is five gallons of gas
right here pretty much dude
okay speaking of that in la it's 5.50
right now
like six and a half over at alameda by
the um train station oh next to the uh
crazy expensive next to the french dip
place yes yes yes 650. in vegas it's
like four right now yeah
yeah i i go uh flex fuel with e85 and
i've never been happier how does that
work is that a different price or yeah
it's like 299. what what wait like my
jeep grand cherokee takes e85 flex fuel
yeah what's flex fuel flex fuel is like
what is that corn oil or some [ __ ] it's
like not actual like regular gasoline
can you make it at home no you use
coconut oil
no because you know some diesel fuels
what they do is they go to the back of
restaurants and all the old oil they'll
take it and they filter it and they
could just pump their diesel trucks with
that kitchen oil no way no way to do it
that sounds so shiny
but it's free a lot of who has that much
free time
it's like joe's [ __ ] smuggling
operation it's the same type of thing
but just like with less payouts
yeah joe's like you take the oil you buy
a plane
you buy a restaurant open a chicken
store
you get all the grease
all the used fried chicken baby so how
many miles per gallon they get on the
e85 stuff well is it jeep grand cherokee
so my miles aren't good i go from like
18 to 20 miles a gallon on the highway
and then maybe like 14 to like 16 on
like the the city yeah but because it's
like three dollars to get a gallon and
my tank is i think 20 gallons where i'm
looking at like 60 to 65 to fill up on
e85 but on regular i'm obviously looking
at like 90 bucks to 100. do you lose
horsepower is it like weaker it's a
little bit weaker and the gas doesn't uh
take as long but because of my normal
commute schedule now and i'm not like
driving like crazy stuff i'm like dude
this is the way but but to get to the
gas station do you waste a half a tank
no okay you know how some people do that
the like the asian moms be like oh i
gotta go get costco gas it's cheaper but
it's like dude but that's like a
20-minute drive and you wait like 12
hours you sit in a parking lot you
already waste a quarter take a gas doing
the getting gas the super the super
chinese fools i know they'll bring
barrels
so they'll go yeah is that legal one of
my vietnamese homies back in his dad
would bring barrels go there fill up the
uh the car and then fill up barrels and
so he has barrels of gas at home like
the little red things are you talking
about a giant a giant thing that he
later puts into the red thing that's
dope to put into his just makes you look
like the unibomber when you do that yeah
it's a fire hazard as [ __ ] you leave
there well they're asians so you know
it's easy you know
all right no threat are you guys ready
for our next bag does that we gotta
taste the action take my money go we're
all excited here it has the biggest odds
take your winnings and put it in it
doesn't know what the bet is just take
your winnings let's go do the right
thing so here's what we're doing here's
what we're doing whatever the biggest
odds is i'm in on barons on barons and
there's a couple other places too you
can bet on what the price of gas is
going to be
what's barron's to the moon seven
dollars
it's a really shitty looking website is
it price of gas by oil barrel
is it price of gasoline oil barrel it is
priced against by the barrel yeah yeah
you nerd
well it's because the gas prices
fluctuate because every single gas
station chooses their own you're just
smart dude you're just smart oh damn we
need to put four g's with a commodity
broker to get in [ __ ] this [ __ ] that
sounds like some stock option [ __ ] have
joe pay the commodity broker we'll pay
place the bets how about we bet on some
fights yo
i'm down right all right what's the next
fight saturday
who's the underdog uh jorge mossfield
he's the underdog he's the underdog what
he's the guy that did the flying needles
he's fighting colby covington it's gonna
be a big fight time out have you ever
been on fight i bet all the time do you
what's your win ratio it's hard it's
really it's really hard i bet i'll say
that i bet
so answer the question i just felt the
chill
i've been three times on fights i lost
two of them because part of it i'm
asking the losing coach the losing coach
right here no you're a champion you're a
black belt champion sometimes sometimes
it's hard because when you're betting
with like the boys you're betting on
like who you kind of want to win
sometimes but when you're betting to
like when you're trying to bet and to
win
you're making emotional bets yeah it's a
lot it's a lot of [ __ ]
analysis and it can be kind of hard how
much you're gonna bet you know it's like
a hundred bucks on it who are you
betting on for this one i'm not gonna
touch this one but i think it'd be fun
if we all kind of play a little did you
say i'm not gonna touch this one but i
think it'd be fun if we all touch this
one wait what what what day what day
yeah saturday the saturday [ __ ] i won't
be in vegas till sunday who's gonna be
at vegas first i'll be the biggest no
you won't oh what are you filming
oh [ __ ] none of us
never mind who's going to place the bed
for us stupid idea stupid who's going to
place the bat if no one's invaded we can
all just better michael
is michael invader
yeah he's [ __ ] adult you could do a
bovada that's what i use
you guys use bovada i should play poker
on bovada is that on coinbase yeah
people play roulette my buddies play
roulette on bovada it's like a latvian
uh betting site which is pretty
bovada.lv how do you bet you live in
california how the [ __ ] are you betting
illegally so you do it through bitcoin
actually so you could like get paid out
through bitcoin
like it's crazy bro like this whole boy
i actually learned about bitcoin through
this website you're more dj than i
thought you know
i don't do it a lot i really don't i'm
out of the game
no no no no i'm at the game i'm a little
[ __ ] bro so i only bet like a little
bit here and there but back in the day i
used to bet like 12 fight parlays the
[ __ ] does that mean so you're betting on
exactly it's very similar to the yogurt
no but it's uh you bet on say i want 12
fighters to win i pick those 12 fighters
obviously for parlays you want to bet
too much because then your odds get
smaller and smaller but the payout is
way higher so i used to bet like 10
bucks
and bet like 12 fighters
and sometimes i'll get really close and
get like 500 for you know ten twenty
bucks a little roulette table then but
if you hit all twelve it's like killer
pay and i i have i have like once or
twice but then sometimes you'll get one
decision
that is kind of [ __ ] up uh
that didn't really go to the actual
fighter and then you're like asked out
today's video is brought to you by babel
all right when i was in high school i
tried to learn espanol
i failed miserably because the structure
man the way the classes form you gotta
use a textbook oh my god my eyes it
sucks learning was not very fun and then
when if it's not fun my brain resisted
it yeah but what's awesome with babel
which is a super popular app that has
more than 10 million sold programs out
there it's pretty freaking awesome
because they have really really easy 15
minute lessons and it made it pretty fun
for me yeah 15 minute quick lessons so
they're bite-sized you're able to
understand learn on the go developed by
over a hundred language experts and they
even have speech recognition technology
so you can speak to it and it helps you
with your enunciation this is the modern
way to learn a language and one of my
favorite things is they have a 20-day
money back guarantee so after learning
for 20 days you're like man i still
stupid you can get your money back but
also with bible you have 14 different
languages you could choose from from
like spanish and german in italian go
travel to europe baby yeah french
bonjour right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
off the record that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot
com slash off the record for up to 60
off your subscription
babble your language for life we can't
bet on this fight without you you're the
one that knows everything yeah why are
you not in the game what are you talking
about you literally are just handing
your you're handed money today
robot dude
bart's such a bro
romano
who's gonna win this fight because i did
the expert analysis on the rams i think
it did an excellent job
did i not do an incredible job there we
were also like oh we're going to bed on
rams because they're la
like there was no i didn't say that you
[ __ ] i said
you gave us the analysis aaron donald is
gonna crush this [ __ ] and what happened
him dog crushes [ __ ] a lot he crushed it
a lot should have got mvp
[ __ ] cooper cup dude
he's pretty sick though literally takes
no skill about the heavy favorite anyway
the point is is that what do you think's
gonna happen i think the guy jorge
monster doll is fighting uh colby
covington
golf muttons is that what they call them
i don't know i just made it up okay i
was like is that you
i was like okay uh you're not allowed to
give me [ __ ] for the rest of the day
but i think colby covington has a really
good shot at winning i think like 80
percent chance colby coming to my
problem
my problem is he sounds like a kid from
my neighborhood that i could beat up and
he kind of looks like it he kind of
looks like he could beat him first and
he's going to beat jorge maslow 80 i
think so i think so just style-wise
right especially when you're betting you
have to take that into account for
fighting it's like the fighting style of
one individual how that matches up with
a moment kobe covington if you guys
don't know
he is like a five round war machine
uh jorge mazvidal is a one round michael
jordan so that's why the style is so
exciting because in one round this guy
could make the crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] happen
but if you don't make it out of that
first round this guy will make your life
a living hell for five rounds yeah like
he will [ __ ] you up so who are you guys
baiting on well massive doll's underdog
and i like him so i bet on massive
though part of me feels like there is
room for an upset which one's the
michael jordan guy mas vidal mosfido
he's excited he'll do he's a michael
jordan guy what's that mean like he can
do like the craziest like three three
minute hang time in the air type 300
books on michael
[Laughter]
he can do the [ __ ] that like they're
like oh my god that was [ __ ]
impossible right like that like the
usain bolt sprinting and then looking at
second place like smiling type of [ __ ]
um but if he doesn't do that in the
first round then you got a guy that like
makes your life a living hell i'ma be
honest i'm gonna give you some pushback
i think i think you're giving him a
little too much credit cool wow
here's my favorite thing that he said
he's a five-round
war machine with those pauses i'm like
whoa he's cutting the [ __ ]
correct
promo
that is correct yes right but the
michael jordan yeah the one round
michael jackson come on i just like them
maybe i just like them dude yeah michael
b jordan or what are we talking about b
jordan dude give me michael b jordan on
the fight
who nailed that fight all right michael
jordan with a twisted ankle
you're just betting on the outcome of
fruitvale station the more we're talking
about it the more i feel like we should
have been
i'm like backtracking now is he coming
in as killmonger no he's not
unfortunately so then i don't know i
don't know so who are you gonna bet on
the one run michael j fox
obviously what the [ __ ] yeah i think i
think i'm gonna bet on the other guy
michael j fox yeah i think if i if i'm
gonna win if i'm doing like steve
analysis with the super bowl i think
smart money is for colby covington but
the odds are probably too high on him
for it to be worth it oh really so
everyone thinks he's going to win he's
the favorite i think he's like a plus
like a minus 250 or something oh no [ __ ]
i barely know what that means
so you got to bet uh 250 to 100 dollars
you know what's interesting though is
both of these guys are trump supporters
oh interesting trump versus trump donald
might actually show up and get a phone
and call both of them give him a salute
because both of them have been in their
like winning interview like trump calls
them and he they pick up like oh my god
hey how's it going yeah i just won like
they wear the magazines yeah
like back when trump was president too
so and he actually came to one of the
fights to watch him fight
and he was like there with the secret
service and everything so we'll see dude
every one of these [ __ ] has a
trump head on
it's gonna be all like every ufc fighter
ufc is kind of a trump spot i think
but i think i think for for jorge he's
from his his parents are cuban he's from
cuba so he's like very like
republican
anti-socialism you know hey that's
i'm surprised they're not fighting at
the trump tower you know what i mean but
they don't have a stadium so i get it
but they should use our room you know
where the fight is where's the fight
it's in vegas right yeah
yeah they should fight where we [ __ ]
imagine if they fought where we yeah
recorded jk news at probably wouldn't
have a lot of ticket sales
well we could watch online in the lobby
intimate theater they probably would say
no
should've went to circus circus yeah
yeah no what uh so
i was gonna what was i gonna say oh yeah
about um
jorge
have you seen him lose a fight before
and how did he lose he's been knocked
out it's like round two he only has the
power in round one he's lost by decision
you know what i mean so i feel like
style wise this is the tough way is this
does he have quit in his i think so i
don't think he has quit but it's just
like the guy he's fighting himself but
as far as like like if we're talking
about sports betting there's no other
sport that's more fun to bet than fights
i think because that's so unpredictable
especially in the u.s
what about
ping pong
can we can we place bets on ping-pong
there's this there's this one fight that
just happened i don't even know who it
is but uh he got socked in the orbital
and his [ __ ] eye came out what the
[ __ ] are you talking about i came out
he's selling it
like you could probably bet on a fight
to end by a doctor stoppage so like an
injury like that
and you could probably get a really good
payout that's a joe style bet look like
we're talking like cartoon now are we
talking about guinness world record typo
nah not too crazy it was like it just
was it was just yeah it just kind of
popped up i feel like it's back home to
sit there and go i hope he gets taken
into orbital dude
yeah i hope there's a drastic injury to
happen
[ __ ] oh there's a guinness world record
wow all right so who we bet on them
who's going to be you you pick me we'll
bet who do you want are we going to yeah
you have the bogota account we're going
to send you money i'm going to send you
money for the underdog for the underdog
how how who do you want to win aside
from odds like just like which fighter
do you like i kind of want to see jorge
win why because he likes trump more or
cause he likes trump less
he i think he likes trump more i think
he's really about it okay that's how
you're basing your back i think well
that's a character the other guy is
doing a [ __ ]
so check this out this guy colby
cummington he was about he was he was
winning all his fights
seven fight win streak
the ufc was like hey you're too boring
we're going to cut you because it all
wins by decision and you're like you're
beating you're you're you're beating the
shell these all these guys you're making
it look easy nobody really cares to
watch you fight
but
the fight the night they told him like
hey you're going to get cut he goes and
fights in brazil
he's fighting a brazilian guy a legend
in brazil right after the fight ends he
goes
brazil you're a stinking dump you guys
are all dogs and you guys are all trash
he yells to the hole like and he's just
talking [ __ ] he's like i beat the [ __ ]
out of your brazilian
life but yeah and
people in brazil they don't play they
[ __ ] go to your hotel room they'll
like
other uh brazilian uh ufc fighters got
in fights with him at the hotel after
that fight
so like he was getting death threats
everywhere but he [ __ ] those foes up
too though because that'd be crazy nah
he was like stop chill chill chill chill
and like it's a prank bro yeah yeah kind
of he kind of he kind of pulled that's
my character yeah but then he got really
popular
they kept him in the ufc and now he's
headlining all now he does that every
city he goes and that's his strength so
so he does like the kind of like a corny
professional wrestler stick but he's
like trump this trump that
and that's what he does now and he's
very popular and he shows up with these
hot chicks then when the cameras are off
he's like doing harvard hands because he
doesn't really want to he's a gentleman
wow okay he's kind of like a fake he's
really like doubly down on his character
he's like it's interesting obama was my
favorite president
uh what i love about the ufc too is that
like it's at staples right or it's at um
t-mobile yeah t-mobile but they had they
used to have about all the casinos but
then dana white kept cleaning him out
because he's such a good blackjack
player dude so then he would he would
they would say like you can't play
blackjack anymore we love you here we
love you coming to our hotels we love
you and he's like cool i'm pulling the
ufc out [ __ ] you yeah and so he
basically can't
go any to any hotels now he's going to
the [ __ ] t-mobile center because
there's no gambling there yeah that's so
crazy
in my [ __ ] grocery store
for christ's sake he's that good at
blackjack yeah because he just count
cards
he openly just counts it and he's all
like spreading his bets really big
because he's a [ __ ] bazillionaire
right so he's all like
um i'mma pay the minimum and then when
the count is favorable to me i'm just
gonna raise it like a [ __ ] and
rake in like so he wins big and loses
small
he loses a lot he loses a lot but it's
still small comparable to what he wins
so yeah scary they call him advantage
players it's not illegal you can't you
can count cards it's not illegal okay
because you're just using your brain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you